you might have learned the other day
that Russia had a quote election in
which Vladimir Putin quote did really
well
receiving quote almost 77% of the vote
then we all woke up from that total
fantasy world as dozens and dozens of
videos of people literally stuffing
ballot boxes with stacks of ballots have
been released we have a ton of videos of
this the Washington Post put one
together where you can see people just
putting stacks of paper into these
ballots and of course the defense has
been well that all these individuals
might have collected a bunch of people's
ballots and put them in at once do you
see that that's how the polling place is
set up I mean where where are these
ballots coming from it makes absolutely
no sense and in order to make the absurd
77% of the vote number that Putin
supposedly received appears slightly
more mathematically believable the
opposition leader Alexei Navalny says
that the official turnout numbers were
also inflated reported as sixty seven
point five percent Navalny saying that
that's actually like ten percentage
points higher than the real turnout
again this is according to opposition
candidate Navalny 77 cent percent for
Vladimir Putin the highest ever in a
Russian presidential election now you
might say to me hey David listen
stuffing ballots into ballot boxes is a
really low-tech and inefficient way to
help Putin if there was real centralized
corruption here you would do it in some
other way you're not gonna physically
send people out there to stuffed ballot
boxes well that's right but what you're
forgetting is Putin didn't need these
votes to win right I'm not saying Putin
would have lost without the ballot
stuffing what I'm saying is he wouldn't
have won by as much it would have just
been much closer I don't even know that
Putin necessarily needs to be in on this
Pat because local governments want to
please Putin the last thing you want to
be is the local official whose district
didn't have a solid turnout for Putin so
I'm not even alleging necessarily that
Vladimir Putin was directly coordinating
this but it'd be defense's
just laughable oh here's one Putin's
approval rating is something like 81%
83% and that's in line with the
percentage of the vote that he got well
button them in five must have been fine
there's absolutely no problem whatsoever
one other funny video to show you here's
someone places a grew a bunch of
balloons right in front of the camera at
a polling place a woman walks over and
then just casually all of a sudden
exactly where the camera is she just
moves a bunch of balloons right in front
but this is just the best isn't it I you
know you would think that at this point
we would we would want to be beyond this
type of stuff but we were not and a
funny defense of the videos is okay fine
listen David you're right it's ballot
stuffing but we don't know which
candidates supporters are stuffing the
ballots you can't say for sure that
those are Putin ballots that are being
stuffed in there give me a break
right in order to believe that these
were opposition ballots stuffings you
have to first explain how were they able
to get away with that despite putin's
cronies controlling endless numbers of
polling places and that would also imply
it but imply that putin didn't just set
a record with 77% of the vote he
arguably had even more of the vote but
because of opposition ballot stuffing
the number was inaccurately low i mean
who would believe that stuff you've got
yeah I spend disbelief in total to
believe people are still questioning
whether or not Russia influenced the
u.s. presidential election they're doing
it for their own elections of course
they are there is a tweet that was put
out by Edward Snowden about this as well
and this is twice now that I'm quoting
Edward Snowden today and I am no a big
defender of Snowden but when he says
something that I believe is accurate
I'll tell you snowden tweeted the ballot
stuffing seen today in moscow and
elsewhere in the russian election is an
effort to steal the influence of a
hundred and forty million plus people
demand justice demand laws and courts
that matter
take your future back want to make one
other comment about this okay and this
is a comment about the toxic left as i'm
calling it that's taking feverish notes
now there is this contingent i've
mentioned before of sort of
Leninist Hugo Chavez loving so-called
leftists who are saying there's nothing
to see in terms of Russian influence in
the United States there's nothing to see
in terms of ballot stuffing in Russia
either we have irregularities here in
the United States as well so who are we
to pass judgment on what's going on in
Russia's elections have fun with that
just stay away from me I have no
interest in even engaging with you
discuss this with us on our subreddit
david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t
coming up next I'm ready for this good
old-fashioned exorcism
stay with us today's program is brought
to you in part by celcius which is a new
global peer-to-peer financial platform
that connects holders of cryptocurrency
assets with borrowers and it will also
allow crypto holders to earn interest on
their assets in the form of coins or get
US dollar loans against their crypto
assets it's sort of like how having a
savings account at a bank works right
just by having crypto in your celcius
wallet you'll earn interest on that
crypto but unlike a bank
this is blockchain based your coins
become part of a decentralized and
crowd-sourced lending pool and you'll be
able to earn interest daily without the
profits going to traditional financial
institutions and you can instantly
borrow against your own coins and
Celsius intends to lend only with
single-digit interest rates regardless
of credit score and Celsius sort of
wants to stick it to Wall Street and
revolutionize the financial industry and
they are running an IC o---- an initial
coin offering which you can learn more
about at Celsius dot Network slash crowd
sale in the u.s. it's open only to
accredited investors and you can sign up
at Celsius dot Network slash crowd sale
this is not financial advice please do
your own research and due diligence
before making any financial decision